[Music]
all of us would probably know that the
pH of assets is less than seven that of
salts is seven and that of bases is more
than seven do we really understand what
pH is let's dive a bit deeper into this
concept okay let's start with the basics
how do we identify if a substance is an
acid or a base that's right
we use an indicator but given two acidic
solutions how do we know which one is
stronger amongst them how can we judge
how strong an acid or a basis and that's
what pH helps us with it gives us the
measure of the strength of acids or
bases how does it do that the pH takes
into account the concentration of H+
ions in the solution yes the pH measures
the strength of acids and bases but
you'd probably be thinking that if pH
only considers the concentration of H+
ions how can it tell us how strong a
basis remember bases also contain H+
ions just that the concentration of h+
ions is far lower than that of the
concentration of O h minus ions so low
that they are generally ignored so to
know how strong an acid or a basis we
have the concept of a pH scale and it
ranges from zero to fourteen zero being
very acidic and fourteen being very
basic or alkaline and the pH of a
neutral solution right here in the
middle is seven understand that the pH
is just a number which tells us how
acidic or basic a solution is more the
concentration of the hydrogen ion lesser
will be the pH value yes understand this
well more the concentration of the
hydrogen ion lesser will be the pH value
now if you look at the scale as we go
towards the left the pH value is
decreasing which means that if we go
leftwards on the scale
the
H+ ion concentration increases and as we
go right words the H+ ion concentration
reduces and we know that higher H+ ion
concentration implies that the solution
is more acidic so the acidic nature
increases as we go towards the left and
as basic solutions have lower
concentration of H+ ions the basic
nature increases as we go towards the
right so this pH scale is a very general
way to understand how strong an acid or
a base is let's take a very basic test
to check if you've understood the
concept of pH scale I have two solutions
a and B solution a has pH of 2 and
solution B has a pH of 4 which one is
more acidic yes
solution a is more acidic as its pH is
lower here's another one solution C has
pH of 5 and solution D has a pH of 10
which one is more basic note that
solution C is acidic and solution D is
basic so relatively solution D is more
basic and we can see that it's pH is
higher to a good way to remember this is
to think of the first two letters of the
English alphabet a and b acidic on the
left and basic on the right and don't
forget we still don't know how the
number on the pH scale is calculated
that involves logarithms but we haven't
looked at yet but how is the pH of a
solution actually measured in real life
we'll see that in the next video
you
[Music]